[Music]
curiosity and exploration are simply
part of our dna what's at the top of
that mountain what's around that ridge
what's in that forest what's across that
body of water this quest to explore
things that we think might be beyond our
reach or might test our courage or our
abilities the drive to explore has been
an important part in making our species
as successful as it's been
for the eyes of the world now look into
space to the moon and to the planets
beyond
one there's no end to what we can
achieve if we put our mind to it
[Music]
there are other destinations that
perhaps are within our grasp
i think there are a lot of surprises in
store for us
the holy grail that we're searching for
is a planet like earth
attento control you know
we are located in the array operation
site at 16 400 feet
so we are in the north of chile here at
the european southern observatory
site of the very large telescope what do
we do with them we observe the universe
at large from asteroids comets planets
stars nebulas in the general sea
in the 21th century astronomy had to
answer a very basic question if there is
another planet like our own planet
an exoplanet is very simply a planet
that's orbiting a star other than the
sun
20 years ago the idea of detecting
exoplanets was considered to be totally
science fiction and not worthy of a
professional astronomer
now exoplanets is one of the hottest
fields in astronomy and is still growing
the potential for habitable planets
billions of planets and planets the
biggest batch of planets ever unveiled
the kepler telescope has discovered
thousands of new planets small planets
are extremely common the kepler mission
was the first mission to do a large
statistical survey and has really
contributed dramatically to our
understanding of exoplanets it has
essentially taught us that planets are
everywhere roughly one out of every two
stars has a potentially habitable planet
the number of potentially habitable
planets in our galaxy alone is greater
than the number of people alive on earth
and they're something like 100 billion
galaxies in the universe all these new
planets are incredibly diverse nature is
more creative than
most of the imaginative scientists out
there
for the first decade or so the planets
that were being found were large gas
giants these hot jupiters that are
orbiting very close to the sun these are
not habitable planets they're more like
tiny stars
we know from the kepler data that
earth-sized planets are also
rather numerous
over the past five years astronomers
have been finding smaller and smaller
planets closer and closer to the
habitable zone we call it the goldilocks
zone where the temperature is just right
you're going to support liquid water you
don't want it to be too hot or too cold
what kepler's done is discover that most
stars have planets many are in a
habitable zone a fair number of them are
earth-sized
we have evidence now we can move to the
next step do those planets have oceans
do they have atmospheres kepler was
never designed to do that
you need a different kind of instrument
more powerful missions to look much more
carefully at these planets
we want something like earth
the problem is finding planets like the
earth is really hard it's extremely
difficult to be able to see a planet
that is 10 billion times dimmer than the
star you see there are lots of stars
here that aren't highlighted and we know
statistically there should be planets
around them and many earth-like planets
but current detection techniques are not
capable of detecting small planets even
around the nearest stars
the star is much much brighter than the
planet this is like looking at a
searchlight and trying to find a little
firefly buzzing around the searchlight
from a large distance like 10 miles one
way of doing it is with a device called
a coronagraph a disc placed artificially
in a telescope in front of the sun's
disk to block the stars so you can see
the planet
indeed nearby stars are easier to study
we happen to be lucky our solar system
has not one but two nearby sun-like
stars alpha centauri a and alpha
centauri b right there we have that
bright
yellow star is alpha centauri alpha
centauri is very similar to our own sun
it's the closest star 4.3
light year from us
so it's our neighbor
these two stars could very well host
earth-like worlds
it's close enough so if you could find
planets around it you could study those
planets
we could potentially make one of the
greatest discoveries of all time another
earth-like planet
we might call it earth proxima
a lot of people realized that alpha
centauri is an easy target
except for the fact that it's a binary
so you have two stars that you have to
deal with in terms of blocking their
light
that's where most people's thinking
stopped
these scientists at nasa ames research
center have been working for a number of
years to take on this challenge kepler's
completed its job it's time to move on
to more capable missions
that project is called mission center
mission centaur is a small telescope to
find and if they're found study planets
in the habitable zones of alpha centauri
a and alpha centauri b we developed a
technique called multi-star wave control
which solves this problem it's the key
component that allows us to suppress the
light from both stars
this is a prototype of the primary
mirror the final telescope is going to
be packed on a spacecraft the size of a
washing machine the best conditions for
astronomical observations are in the
outer space the problem for space
telescopes well same problem of entire
science
budget
space missions are particularly
expensive what they try to do is to
observe many targets
by doing that you're adding a lot of
complexity and cost the better way to go
is to study the closest sun-like stars
for which you can use a much smaller
spacecraft for much much less money the
beauty of mission center is when you
decide that the target is alpha centauri
all the time you can optimize your
telescope we can do it with a much lower
cost and a much smaller mission and do
it much faster this is a project whose
whose operating budget is a fraction of
a typical huge budget project such as
hubble or even kepler we've entered a
new age and companies like spacex are an
example of the commercialization now of
space space missions are getting more
and more practical year by year private
industry is comfortable with calculated
risks a lot of the expertise is at nasa
so it's a natural partnership between
nasa and the private sector to enable
this mission
this is a program for for everyone this
is a citizen science project that not
only is profound in its primary mission
but potentially profound in its
secondary mission
the earth is going to block the line of
sight to alpha centauri half of the time
when the telescope cannot observe alpha
centauri we expect to offer telescope
time to different people that are
interested in exploring the universe
that's part of what we want to achieve
with mission center is empower people
to feel like they can have access to
state-of-the-art technology
we are enabling all of this exciting
science so that we can excite our kids
to become the next generation of
scientists and engineers who will be the
drivers of the economy of the future
if we find earth proxima it would
fundamentally shift people's perception
of what the cosmos is
finding an earth proxima would be a
transformative event in the history of
mankind i would love to think that that
is something that helps bring us
together it's a very unifying thing how
could you worry about conflicts on earth
when there's amazing awe-inspiring
things like this in the universe i look
forward with a lot of enthusiasm to new
missions that take those new steps and
the sooner the better
so i see what we're doing as part of
this hopeful future where humanity
expands out into the stars
it would be a milestone of the human
civilization to find another planet like
the earth
[Music]
you